antes de que estudiemos con mayor
profundidad la meiosis lo que quiero
hacer es darte una visión general de las
diferencias entre mitosis y meiosis en
la mitosis si viste los vídeos de
mitosis todo esto es un resumen así que
déjame escribirlo en la mitosis
empezamos con una célula que tiene un
número diploide de cromosomas así que
déjame dibujar por aquí en una célula y
esta célula va a tener un número
diploide de cromosomas así que voy a
poner aquí dos en dos
para mostrar que la célula tiene un
número diploide en los seres humanos
este número de aquí es de 46 cromosomas
recuerda 46 para
los
ahora bien tú tienes 23 cromosomas de tu
mamá y 23 cromosomas de tu papá también
puedes decir que tienes 23 pares
homólogos lo que lleva a 46 cromosomas y
bueno después de que sucede la mitosis
ya que sucedió las citocinas y si todo
lo demás vas a obtener lo siguiente vas
a obtener dos células vas a terminar con
dos células voy a poner una por aquí y
la otra por acá y cada una de ellas
tiene el mismo material genético que la
célula original entonces ahora tienes
dos células con un número diploide de
cromosomas 2n y está también un número
diploide de cromosomas 2
y bueno cada una de estas células es
idéntica a la célula anterior
estas nuevas células pueden entrar a
interfaces crecer replicar su adn sus
centros o mama y continuar creciendo y
después pueden entrar en mitosis de
nuevo y de hecho por medio de este
proceso es como la mayoría de las
células de nuestro cuerpo crece así que
de esta manera es como nos formamos es
como te formaste tú a partir de una sola
célula pero bueno esto es la mitosis es
un ciclo después de que las células
entran en mitosis pueden tener un ciclo
celular completo de nuevo ahora qué va a
pasar con la meiosis en la meiosis
déjame ponerlo aquí la me
o si en la medios y lo que vamos a ver
es lo siguiente
bueno pues va a pasar algo ligeramente
distinto y sucede en dos fases al igual
que la mitosis vamos a empezar con una
célula una célula que tienen un número
diploide de cromosomas va a tener esta
también un número diploide de cromosomas
y por eso voy a poner aquí dos en y
durante la interfase esta célula también
replica su adn pero luego entran en una
fase llamada meiosis 1 y en la meiosis 1
vamos a terminar con dos células que
ahora tienen un número aplaude de
cromosomas vamos de un número a floyd de
cromosomas así que deben ponerle aquí la
otra por acá y ahora en lugar de 2n voy
a escribir solamente
igual aquí en lugar de 2n voy a escribir
solamente n si hablamos de los seres
humanos bueno aquí tienes 46 cromosomas
y 23 cromosomas en este núcleo y otros
23 en este otro núcleo pero hasta que no
termina lo que va a pasar después es lo
siguiente cada una de estas células de
estas nuevas células entran a una nueva
fase que es muy similar a la mitosis
donde se duplican cada una de estas
células y se obtienen dos así que
déjenme ponerlo así voy a sacar dos de
cada una de estas aquí voy a poner n
porque cada una va a terminar con un
número a lloyd de cromosomas aquí
también y aquí también y déjame dibujar
estas cuatro células aquí voy a tener
una de ellas aquí voy a tener otra de
ellas aquí otra de ellas y bueno aquí
también otra de ellas y ojo estas
células no necesariamente tendrán la
misma información genética esto debido a
que conforme pasa
la fase de la meiosis es decir la fase
en donde pasan de diploides a floyd es
justo este de aquí déjame escribirlo me
y oh sí
y este de aquí es la primera fase
esencialmente se separan los pares
homólogos entonces esta célula de aquí
puede obtener cromosomas que
originalmente obtuviste de tu papá y
originalmente obtuviste de tu mamá y
están también puedes obtener cromosomas
que originalmente obtuviste de tu papá o
de tu mamá los cromosomas se separan
aleatoriamente pero cada par homólogo se
separan ahora en esta segunda fase que
tengo aquí en esta segunda fase que
tengo aquí que le voy a poner
62 en esta fase es muy parecida a la
mitosis pero ahora iniciamos con células
que tienen un número aplauden de
cromosomas y es muy importante remarcar
que después de la meiosis las células no
tienen un ciclo celular de nuevo estas
células que tenemos aquí son gametos son
células sexuales déjenme escribir lo son
es decir células que participan en la
fertilización si eres un hombre esto
sucede en tus testículos y estas células
serán tus espermatozoides y si eres
mujer esto sucede en tus ovarios y una
de estas células va a ser un óvulo
funcional las otras tres se van a
degenerar si tú fueras un árbol bueno
estas células podrían ser un grano de
polen o un óvulo entonces las células
obtenidas durante la meiosis participan
en la fertilización éstas se funcionarán
durante la reproducción sexual lo que
dará lugar a un cigoto el cual entrará
en la mitosis para crear un nuevo
organismo entonces las células de la
meiosis no entran en ningún ciclo estas
células posiblemente encontraran a las
células sexuales de otro organismo se
fusionarán con ellas para dar lugar a un
nuevo ser viviente y podemos decir que
es así como inicia un nuevo ciclo de
vida y justo esto no
con la mitosis donde las células puedan
seguir y seguir reproduciéndose pero
estas células está de aquí va a ser
idéntica a esta otra que tenemos aquí
mientras que estas otras células éstas
aquí son distintas a la célula original
y bueno en qué parte del cuerpo suceden
la mitosis ya hablamos de esto en vídeos
anteriores recuerdas la mitosis ocurre
en todas las células somáticas así que
déjame ponerlo aquí en sí
las sol
y gas estas son las que forman la mayor
parte de tu cuerpo y donde sucede la
meiosis bueno estas son células
germinales
las germinales
y
no les y son las que entran en meiosis
como ya mencionamos si eres hombre estas
células estarán en tus testículos y si
eres mujer éstas estarán en tus ovarios
por cierto las células germinales tanto
pueden entrar en mitosis y así producir
otras células germinales que tienen un
número diploide de cromosomas como
pueden entrar en meiosis y así producir
espermatozoides y óvulos es decir
gametos